what to wear on football's biggest stage
cameroon's team are caught in a legal
battle about which kit they can debut in
the upcoming World Cup
one manufacturing company had the deal
but that was canceled in July switching
sponsorship rights to another company
now the market is flooded with the old
shirts and few of the new ones are
available
I'm very happy to be the first
cameroonian to have bought this shirt
which I will wear proudly Mall
Cameroon and the canceled Sports
supplier are now in court trying to
resolve which Jersey the team will end
up wearing in Qatar you have a kit
supplier that wants to hang on to its
contracts you have a new kit supplier
the market the cameronian market console
camera in a few days ago is flooded with
jerseys that were made by lecock sportif
obviously because the Jersey is produced
by one all sports are not yet gone on
sale but it's a very complex situation
as you did mentioned
Cameroon has a history of Kit drama in
2002 FIFA banned its uniform saying
players must wear sleeves
so the team showed up to play with black
shirts under their vests then two years
later the squad was fined for wearing a
one-piece kit but competed in the
African Cup of Nations with it anyway
fans say the current dispute doesn't
overshadow their ability to perform
it's a satisfaction for us and a relief
for cameroonians now we can focus on the
adventure of Qatar with the indomitable
lion Cameroon will play their Opening
match against Switzerland on November
24th how they'll look they still don't
know Leah Harding Al Jazeera